el estancamiento político se extiende en
Líbano el parlamento fracasó por décimo
primera vez en su intento Designar un
presidente un problema que suscita
crisis económicas sociales y energéticas
ante esta situación la población se
manifestó en las calles de beirut
Puede unirse por el bien del Líbano y su
gente Entonces de qué sirve el
parlamento no lo queremos
el país no puede soportar otro día de
vacancia presidencial Pero hay algunos
bloques políticos que honestamente no
tienen ninguna responsabilidad ni ningún
tipo de sentimiento humano hacia los
libaneses para que podamos impulsar una
solución económica y política
el parlamento libanés está dividido en
dos facciones de un lado Los partidarios
del poderoso movimiento gesbolar que
cuenta con el apoyo de Irán del otro sus
opositores una polarización en donde
ninguno tiene una mayoría Clara el vacío
de poder ha repercutido en la vida de un
país donde la mitad ni siquiera tiene
electricidad
el tema de la electricidad es un tema de
suma importancia se trata de aumentar
las horas de suministro eléctrico y creo
que si logramos resolver la crisis
eléctrica resolveríamos más del 50 por
ciento de los problemas del pueblo
libanés
que se produjo una crisis financiera sin
precedentes a finales del 2019 la moneda
ha perdido el 95% de su valor frente al
Dólar sumiendo a gran parte de la
población en la pobreza y con un Banco
Central bajo investigación europea por
corrupción la vacante presidencial deja
al Líbano sin líderes ante las crisis y
con un mandatario interino con apenas
poderes provisionales